[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein piano rezept
also die vapiano reihe die wächst und
wächst letztes mal hatten wir das pesto
rosso und heute machen wir pikante ich
muss immer an dich denken haben haben
sie gestellten immer immer immer zu 90%
ich hin und wieder aus so haben auch
schon richtig hunger und ihr habt auch
dieser kleidung muss uns profi kante
zeigen und wenn ihr jetzt sehen wie
einfach das ist ich glaube immer halb
januar also tut noch richtig leid ich
mag gerne aber es geht auch wirklich
einfach und ja auf jeden fall brauchen
wir natürlich nudeln ich zeige euch
jetzt hier nicht wie man nur den kopf
das ist ja quatsch ich zeige euch jetzt
hier weitere zutaten einmal
hähnchenbrust dann habe ich paprika
flocken könnte auch der dicke flocken
nehmen mini pak choi orangen neutrales
öl hier habe ich honig und irgendwie
paprika und habe ich salz und pfeffer
natürlich und süß saurer soße so wir
starten jetzt auch direkt ich weiß dass
ihr alle wisst wie man paprika klein
schnippelt wie man hähnchenbrust klein
schneidet und deshalb zeige ich euch das
nicht unnötig aber was ich euch zeige
ist hier dieses mini packt ich weiß
nicht ob da jeder von euch schon mal
erfahrung mit hatte fakt ist ihr könnt
es komplett wo essen
das ist gar kein problem daher benutze
ich die blätter für den salat gekommen
jetzt nicht in die pfanne sondern wir
nehmen nur die festen bestandteile
ich schneide jetzt im strunk ab und den
rest scheint ihr in mundgerechte stücke
[Musik]
so das öl ist in der pfanne macht ruhig
die mittlere stufe an und reibt schon
mal euren ingwer in die pfanne und gibt
dann auch das hin zum vielleicht schon
mit dazu
[Musik]
das finde ich sehr knapp vier minuten
anbraten und dann das gemüse zu gehen
und dann brachte er das weitere zwei
minuten an
und jetzt können einfach alle anderen
zutaten mit hinzugegeben werden noch mal
ungefähr eine minute ein bisschen
köcheln lassen
und dann ist es auch schon fertig main
über plan ist es ja auch so da geht's
auch ziemlich schnell
[Musik]
zum schluss nur noch die gekochten
nudeln ein fachunternehmen und dann
könnt ihr es sich einfach nur noch
können und habe zugenommen was ihr mir
gesagt habt ich soll fossilien nehmen
und daher habe ich das jetzt so gemacht
ihr könnt natürlich auch andere nudeln
nehmen das dürft ihr euch aber am piano
auch aussuchen und ich werde euch wie
immer die ganz genauen mengenangaben
unten in die video beschreibung
hineinschreiben
und weil sie das hier angeschaut habt
hinterlasst auf jeden fall ein
kostenloses abo und schreibt mir in die
kommentare welches war piano gericht ich
als nächstes machen soll
ich weiß dass dieses kabarett ist dass
das auch ziemlich beliebt ist günther
keine gerne man lernt einfach freunde
ein wie das verputzen können das ist
auch nötig schreibt mir auf jeden fall
eure vorschläge haben sie und ich es
nicht in aller ruhe erstmal ist ruh die
elf in die foto und dann aber dann okay
ich wünsche euch jetzt noch einen
wunderschönen tag und wir schreiben in
den kommentaren mit einer nah bis bald
tschüss
[Musik]